- Hey guys, another episode of Overrated
Underrated with me,
Gary Vee.
♪ Overrated or underrated ♪
♪ What does Gary think ♪
- I'm really, really
excited about this show.
I know it's
a show that a lot of people are enjoying.
D Rock.
Actually, we just posted, ironically
as we're filming this,
the latest episode.
- Uh, Scooby-Doo
- Scooby-Doo is overrated.
A commercial I liked
quite a bit as a kid, but
it's just
I really think
it's just, okay.
You love Scooby-Doo?
- No.
- You seemed very sad.
- [D Rock] (indistinct) I like
IP and it's really good IP.
- It's great IP I just, I don't think it's
as great as people think.
(D Rock laughing)
This is my overrated.
You don't agree?
Do your own overrated underrated,
this is my overrated underrated.
- [D Rock] "The Price is Right"?
- Underrated.
It's so funny.
Scooby-Doo and Price
is Right were two shows
that I watched
heavily in 1981
and learned a lot of English from,
but I think "The Price is Right"
is a very underrated show.
And Bob,
Bob Barker was a classic.
So I'm going to go with
slightly underrated.
- [D Rock] Charcuterie board.
- Charcuterie boards are grossly
God, I like them a lot
but I'm eating a lot cleaner these days
and so
I'm going to go with
Underrated.
I still think that it's
such a fun way to eat.
God, just
give me a good charcuterie board
with a nice glass of wine.
And I'm like
in a good place.
- [D Rock] Clubhouse.
- Clubhouse is wildly,
wildly underrated
because most people
don't know about the app
yet
still.
And the voice format, I'm
very fond of Clubhouse the app
just incredibly
fun conversations are going on.
It replicates real life.
Like
what if like 20 people got together?
Eight people, seven people got together
at a dinner table and just
shot the shit.
And then everybody got to listen to it.
I think it's,
it makes sense why it's working.
I love the audio platform.
I love audio as many of you know.
I think Clubhouse is underrated
because I think a year from today
of this filming,
a lot, lot, lot more people will be on it.
- [D Rock] ASMR?
- ASMR is, is
underrated.
I think it really brings
a lot of value to people.
It really helps people focus and
chill and vibe.
I think more people
would appreciate it
if they got into the game.
- [D Rock] Snapchat.
- Now I think Snapchat is
actually underrated right now
as you know D Rock
I'm about to have a real heavy focus.
This is a good opportunity
for people to follow me.
Let's link up my slap,
slap chat.
My Snapchat
public profile.
I'm about to take it very serious.
Snaps made a lot of changes
and there's allowed a little bit more
of a public,
public layer.
And I'm,
I'm really excited about
getting deep into 2021
is the year of Snapchat
for my personal brand.
And I think in general
it is underrated
to a lot of businesses and creators.
- Connor McGregor
- Connor McGregor is
it's funny.
I'm, I'm going to break some news here.
I am buying Connor McGregor rookie cards.
I think I only have three as of right now
but hopefully by the time this airs
I'll have seven or eight.
because I know this will now be out.
I think
Connor McGregor is pretty damn underrated
because I think UFC
is and MMA is underrated
in the macro to begin with.
And I think
the entire mixed martial arts
and fighting scene
will have very good 30, 40 years.
And I think McGregor
kind of like Sugar Ray Robinson
or a McGregor kind of
similar to a Rocky Marsianno.
I think McGregor's one of those names
that twenty-five years
from now is going to be in that five
or six Mount Rushmore
kind of pop culture names.
It's also very focused on,
you know
his spirits brand and
executing in that world.
I think he's underrated.
- Hungarian Wine.
- I mean, Hungarian
Wine is not even rated.
Unfortunately,
I'm dying to know where you guys dug this
up from.
I'm a big fan of Tokaji,
which is a dessert one
from dessert wine from Hungary.
Tokajis were so famous.
200 years ago,
Hungarians, the Russian czars
would trade like 50 men
for like six bottles
of the best Tokaji.
I went to Hungary
to look at vineyards
15 years ago
to possibly start my own Tokaji.
But as much as I know,
the wines are underrated.
I almost have to call
Hungarian wines rated
cause nobody rates them.
So even one person thinks they're good.
They become overrated.
In essence,
it's a truly underrated thing
but this is the first thing I can think of
is like, I don't know
if you got a new symbol
team,
like not rated,
they're just not rated.
I mean
nobody outside of Hungarian descent
humans
thinks about Hungarian wine, which is
too bad.
- [D Rock] A musical theater.
- I love,
I love musical theater.
I, I Broadway musical theater.
I would say
it is
properly rated
because I think you have heavy
Broadway enthusiasts.
And then a bunch of people
who actually don't know
this is probably the first
thing that made me say
I wish a lot of people
would try it.
I think of Broadway and musical theater
in the same way I think of oysters.
I think people just decide they don't
like it
without ever trying it.
I think
a good musical play
is fuckin,
epic.
[Muffled Conversation]
You know,
it's been a minute.
No, no.
I think I've seen
something since Hamilton.
Um,
I don't know.
But Hamilton, Book of Mo-,
Jersey boys, Book of Mormon
like there's so many good,
Wicked.
There's been so many great ones.
- [D Rock] Hamilton.
- No, I don't think Hamilton's right.
- [D Rock] Underrated overrated?
- Oh, we're going to Hamilton?
Um.
At this point.
Probably slightly underrated
18 months ago,
probably slightly overrated.
It's calibrating.
But if you haven't seen it, it is.
I mean, look, you know, this about me.
History is the only class I was good at.
And hip hop is something
I really genuinely one
of the few things I like.
So to me
that was like here,
Gary, here is your show.
And I like,
you know, theater to
begin with probably more
than people realize.
So I think it's underrated
right this second.
Cause it's out of the news cycle
and, and this is
what happens when a classic,
but at the same token, I feel
like it's gone with the wind.
I feel like in 39, 47, 53 years,
people are talking
about Hamilton is like,
that was a great thing.
It'll be redone in different ways.
So pretty amazing.
- [D Rock] Draft Kings.
- Draft King specifically
is properly rated
because it's wildly respected.
It's a big stock it's
but it's a
it's a beast in that space,
sports betting,
daily fantasy
all that.
I would go with properly rating
I think it gets the right amount
of respect
and culture juice for what it is.
- [D Rock] Netflix.
- Netflix is...
That's such a funny back-to-back
cause I feel like my brain thinks
of them the same way
I would go with Netflix being...
I'm gonna go with Netflix being slightly.
And I mean, I hair
overrated
because I think HBO max, Disney plus,
I think you're going to start seeing more
and more
streaming life happening
and like, God
it's so good though.
Such a good product.
It's actually properly rated.
Right? I think the only
reason why I went with
slightly overrated is
because I didn't want to go back-to-back
properly rated
and give the same basic answer
as I did with Draft Kings.
But I really have those
things in the same place.
- [D Rock] A pencil.
- A pencil is overrated.
The fucks a pencil?
Listen, I know there's some
artists that they're sketchers
like pencils are overrated.
Like,
- [D Rock] You think people
like talk about it a lot?
- I think they're overrated.
Like I don't think I'm as
fired up about a pencil.
- [D Rock] Reddit.
- I think Reddit is underrated.
I think the creativity of
Reddit is extraordinary.
And
I think as big as it is
I still think people,
I think it's underrated.
- [D Rock] Anime.
- I think anime is underrated in America.
I don't think it's underrated
everywhere in the world.
But I think as an entertainment form
create creative form.
I think it's underrated.
- [D Rock] Christopher Nolan.
- Christopher Nolan.
- [D Rock] Dark, Dark Knight.
- Yeah yeah.
We have no idea who he is.
My actor and actress,
knowledge is...
Director there you go.
My Hollywood knowledge.
Um,
I can't answer that.
Like I just genuinely don't know.
- [D Rock] I feel like,
he's my favorite director.
- Sorry D Rock.
- [D Rock] Oculus VR.
- Oculus VR
is underrated.
I think VR is on the precipice.
I'm about to kind of go into it.
Um, uh I
have a very funny feeling.
Oculus is underrated.
- [D Rock] Beyond Meat.
- Beyond Meat is
I would argue as underrated
it's
wildly delicious I think.
- [D Rock] Squidward.
- I haven't watched enough SpongeBob to
give a proper answer here.
I like this episode.
There's some curve balls in it for me.
I'm going to go with,
I don't know.
- [D Rock] The Bachelor.
- Uh, The Bachelor.
Wow. What a passion for a lot of people.
I'm going to go with
I'm going to go with overrated.
I know it's extremely big IP.
I know it's an extremely
big time show.
I'm just
not about that life.
- [D Rock] One
college football championship
Ohio vs. Alabama.
- The Ohio State vs.
Alabama championship game
is going to air probably
after the game.
Right. Happens.
So
the match-ups I'm excited about
it should be a great game.
I,
not a really great prediction.
I think Alabama will probably win
but Justin Fields went crazy
in his last game.
So it's such an X factor.
Um, I think it will.
I think all sporting events
are doing well during COVID.
So I'm going to go with underrated
but the hopes that the game
is remarkable.
- [D Rock] Zion Williamson.
- I think Zion, pshh.
As you know,
I haven't bought a single Zion card.
I love Zion
of what I know about him from afar
as a kid.
I really like his game.
I think he's,
he's a tough one for me.
I, I'm getting over
my fear of injuries for him.
I'm going to go with,
I'm going to go with underrated.
I think,
I think because he's a little hurt.
I, or,
you know
historically
I think cause John Ramp was so lit.
I think
that as I sit here right this second,
I think he
he could end up being one
like the best player in the
NBA in four years, five years.
And I don't think people have
that take on him right now
even though they did 15 months ago.
Some feel like,
you know, it's one of those sneaky ones.
So I'm it.
Cause I know this is going
to be recalled one day
and I think it's more likely
that he's a top five NBA
player that he's not.
So I'm going to go
slightly underrated.
- [D Rock] Lil Baby.
- Lil Baby?
Lil Baby?
I think he's very underrated.
I think he's extremely
strong artist.
- [D Rock] Bad Bunny.
- I mean,
you guys are going to have to bring
out people that I don't
know
or as well, like,
you know, I, not personally, I mean
I just like,
you know, I like these artists
so I'm going to go with underrated
now Bad Bunny,
you know
it's so funny with Lil Baby and Bad Bunny.
They're so big now compared
to five years ago when we were listening.
So
they're probably more properly rated.
For me,
they're both underrated.
- [D Rock] Wendy's.
- I like Wendy's, haha!
I do like Wendy's.
Big shout out to Rob Moose.
We used to drive from Calm Ave in Boston
to Foxwoods
on a whim.
We'd be playing video games.
When we first turned 21
and we'd be like
you want to go to the casino?
Yeah.
And we had roommates LA and
Tokyo Jo that weren't 21.
So it was like, let's go.
We go.
And we don't.
I mean, he had like 80
bucks and I like 400 bucks
but we would always stop at Wendy's
on exit three in Rhode Island
before we got into Connecticut
and have Wendy's
and we'd buy like six things.
It was the fucking best.
So for that reason alone
Wendy's is underrated.
Please leave a comment below on
where you most agree
and where you most disagree
with me
on this episode of Overrated
Underrated.
[Whooshing Sound]
YouTube watcher
what's up it's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super well
during these times.
I also
want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment
and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode
stories, polls
more contact,
more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This
is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.